a lot of the things you say are really
like you know common sense I feel like
you know it's it's crazy that it can be
so offensive in these days you know like
it's almost like people are so
um
they're so addicted to lies that the
truth is just offensive to them and you
talk a lot about about uncomfortable
truths what are like your top
uncomfortable truths would you say do
you have like a list of you know rules
yeah
a lot of the stuff that I say Ruffles
feathers but you know as they always say
a bomber only gets Flack when it's over
the target so
um at first it was a little bit odd like
I would spend a lot of time in the
comments section reading them see you
know looking at the feedback from people
in my videos
um and it's always either
because it's true and it hurts their
feelings more it's the white knight sort
of characters the guys that want to
swoop in to sort of protect the honor of
the lady and then they try to attack you
as well because they think that it's
going to win over the intimacy of the
gals that hear that hear or or see them
sort of chime in to support them right
um but the main things that seem to
upset them is when you say promiscuity
is bad for women
um men and women are different
um I mean like I could keep going but
those seem to be like the two big ones
that really catch them um when you start
talking about things like feminism is
toxic or it's not great for the gals it
really doesn't serve Society
um that seems to ruffle a lot of
feathers another one that I that that
women hate a lot and surprisingly well
unsurprisingly it's it's always heavily
tattooed women but when I say that
tattoos are a sign of you know it's a
red flag like it's a woman that you
generally want to try to avoid
um tatted up women's get very upset
they'll they'll have their entire Army
of of uh gals and the white Knights come
in and attack me in comments and stuff
like that single moms whenever I tell
guys to stay away from single moms and
choose women that don't bring children
to the relationship that ticks off
single moms or guys that you know white
knighted for single moms those would be
the main ones though
so yeah I love to dive into the
promiscuity is bad for women because um
you know that that's really kind of what
introduced me to you is that video and
um you know I talk a lot about about
waiting saving sex for marriage is the
book it's really the whole kind of
platform unintentionally that I that I
landed on but you know women will always
say to me
well I don't want to date a guy that's
got a past sexual History either that's
disgusting and I'm thinking in all
honesty it sounds it sounds cocky to say
but like most women that I've
encountered don't really care they're
more worried about the fact that I've
made changes you know uh you know I love
Jesus and I'm headed in a good direction
and I've heard you say in that video
about
um you know when men are more concerned
about a woman's past and men are more
concerned about uh women are more
concerned about a man's future yeah I
find that to be 100 true and women don't
like to hear that especially if they
have a past but really to me it goes
back to the fact of what men and women
are controlling in a relationship so men
a man controls when if and when we get
married he's the one that proposes so he
controls the security a woman controls
if and when we have sex so I always
phrase or pose it like this to women I'm
like imagine if you you met a man and
you fell in love you got engaged and
then you found out he that he proposed
to every woman that he dated before you
how would you feel correct not that
special right I said well that's how men
feel when you're sleeping with everybody
that you dated before them because you
were giving away the thing that you were
out of control over you were just giving
it away and now I'm supposed to be you
know not have feelings about that and
yeah people don't like that yeah it
really Ruffles feathers when you try to
explain to to society that men and women
are different that you know women don't
generally care about a guy's sexual past
they'll they'll look past it if he's a
strong provider and a virtuous alpha
male that you know she wants to be with
for the rest of her life sort of thing
she looks at the guy as her hypergamous
best option it doesn't matter if she if
he if he's been with two gals or 20 or
200
um as long as he can provide but men are
success objects right so that's why
women look at a man's future but women
are Beauty objects to men and it's
always been that way but I think with
you know society today we've got modern
you know this modern version of feminism
which is trying to convince society and
especially women that men and women are
equal they're the same and if you know
what's good for the goose is good for
the gander and that's one of the
narratives that that that just doesn't
sit with me like I don't roll with that
so so when I tell them it's like you
know there's there's going to be
consequences to your promiscuity they
have a very very very hard time
understanding that and they get upset
with it and it's usually the ones that
have a promiscuous past they get very
upset with it but at the same time it's
very difficult to you know sit down with
a 22 year old and say look you know your
value to your future husband is going to
be your your your beauty and the lack of
intimacy that you gave away to other men
right
um there's no guy out there
that has read even a few lines of an EVO
psych blog a Twitter following even like
a little snippet from like a Joe Rogan
interview with one of these Evo psych
guys that doesn't think for a minute for
a minute that a promiscuous woman that's
been with a hundred guys
is not disgusting these women in my
opinion are disgusting and I think guys
innately are repulsed by women that have
been with that many guys right you don't
want to share a woman with that many
guys and if you're if you're planning on
having children why would you want to
share the womb that's been you know used
by other guys right that's why
throughout history virginity was so
valued right to to men and society and
why they tried to protect it it's just
in recent times that they've lied to
women and they've said go out and have
fun guys do it so you should do it too
and that's why we have the society it it
really started with hormonal birth
control you know because you know then
you could go and have sex without
consequences right before there was
consequences if you had sex you could
legitimately get pregnant uh now it's
like they can prevent that almost
completely and very safely 99 of the
time yeah yeah and then of course
abortion is so readily valuable yeah and
then that's the backup plan which really
isn't a you know like a form of birth
control it's just something completely
different everybody you know debates
them merits of it but it's not birth
control yeah so it's important for me to
mention here just my my view because I
it doesn't make it less wrong in God's
eyes I always don't have to say that the
the you know citizen there's
consequences to sin but the the
consequences for promiscuity play out
very differently with men and women
there's plenty of studies to show that
the women with the highest divorce rates
are the ones with the highest sexual
partners exactly the lowest sexual the
lowest divorce rates are the women for
30 years that are the ones that married
with zero to one partner so that's 100
truth in what you're saying and it and
it goes further than that like like
women that have fewer to no Partners
also have lower instances of uh
depression mental disorders suicide
rates
um you know they're more successful
they're happier in long-term
relationships they've got a higher
probability of pair bonding to a male
and a long-term fashion monogamously
they're also less likely you know if
there's conflict in that relationship to
say that's it I'm out I'm going to get a
divorce because you know like a woman
that's done that 50 100 200 times before
what's stopping them from doing it 201
times they've already done it 200 times
they don't care it's easy for them to
get out so you have a woman that was a
virgin when you met them and got married
or have kids for example that's a better
choice than a woman that's been with the
city block right absolutely I mean it is
what it is God can redeem any mistakes
if anybody's out here listening it's not
like God you know you're done and you're
never going to find a husband we're just
saying it does present challenges and
there are consequences to sin which is
why God tells us not to do it in the
first place I really hope you guys
enjoyed that clip if you want to watch
the full length podcast you can find
that over here that clips from if you're
new to the channel make sure you hit
subscribe over here and pin down below
in the top comment you'll find find a
bunch of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out